could you tell us a little bit more
about the relationship between
this breathing technique and the cold
therapy that you're using
yes the cold therapy trains the
cardiovascular system
killer number one in society what is it
cardiovascular related diseases
why because we wear clothes all the time
we are never exposed to the uh the
elements
of nature to cold to heat to pressure
it's always neutral neutral it's like a
muscle
and you don't drain it it's there but it
is this
that is our vascular system our vascular
system is
hundred thousand kilometers long
inside everybody and the thermal
receptors
and the electro receptors they end up in
our biggest organ of ours which is the
skin
we always get it covered logically we
have a cardiovascular related
epidemic pandemic going on
for hundreds of years already
and now i say cold shower a day keeps
the doctor away
okay so how cold and how long that it
begins with 30 seconds
first i explain what you know what
happens when you
go into a cold shower you
activate you stimulate deeply
the thermoreceptors and the
anti-pain receptor pain receptor
thermoreceptors
electro receptors which is the neurology
all connected to the skin they are in
turn they affect the vascular system
the cardiovascular system millions of
little muscles
suddenly are stimulated they begin to
optimize that the blood flow goes a lot
better through the system
that is number one it reaches a lot
better our cells
with oxygen nutrients and vitamins
that's why a cold shower
gives you energy then the second thing
if you regularly
you begin with 30 seconds then you do 45
seconds
one minute one minute and a quarter etc
you go up to two and a half minutes
a day why because that
is the vascular fitness exercise the
best
then cardiovascular related diseases and
that is also
inflammation into the heart inflammation
into our neurology is goodbye
how simple what happens that the heart
rate
when all these little millions of little
primitive muscles
in the hundreds of thousands of uh blood
vessels
inside are activated optimized
then the heart rate suddenly doesn't
need to compensate
for the loss of the vascular condition
and then the heart rate will go
down with 20 to 30 beats a minute
24 hours a day you see what kind of
stress that would be
if you have a weak vascular system
in tone then it takes maybe years maybe
10 years
maybe 20 but it will take its toll
because the heart rate when it goes up
it triggers directly the deliver
to release cortisol and glucose
it's like you are in fighting flight
because the function of our accelerated
heart rate
is to pump glucose and adrenaline
through our system
the fast as possible yeah but now there
is a constant danger
signal going on because of our weight
that's why
cardiovascular related diseases
arteriosclerosis
is logical because the blood flow is not
helped
with these millions of little muscles
who are
weakened they are not stimulated and
then the heart rate needs to
pump 20 to 30 a minute 24 hours a day
day in day out day and hey man it will
take us all
soon or later so if the people they
gotta wake up
cold shower the best thing you can do
for yourself is a cold shower
how cool just to call
take turn them too cold
that is creating the stimulation you
start with 30 seconds
yes it begins with 30 seconds because i
say
don't force because yeah
any maybe 90 of the people
go well you guys you will go well
young woman that goes well no problem
hey uh if you have a condition any
then it is because of one of you of the
system
there is a defect going on it will
boost at that moment the system and it
will go through
a good job so that's why i said
uh safety first 30 seconds to begin with
but within 10 days anybody is able to do
the same
to go to two and a half minutes no
problem
culture within 10 days within 10 days
your cardiovascular system is
is improved so much
the way nature meant to be and the way
nature meant
to be is that the skin is we have skin
we have electro receptors and thermal
receptors and pain
receptors all go into the skin to give
us the information
of what is going out uh aside in
in in life would you recommend
covering it up would you recommend doing
this in the morning or
or in the afternoon or the evening
whenever you take the shower
okay you take them nice and warm etc
it's all nice but then to also take the
cold one
it's the best they what they saw
uh with a cold water we we just
recently have uh done a new study on
that
it really improves within 10 days the
cardiovascular system
which is directly related to the
neurology by the way yeah
neurologic the the opening and closing
of
all those the activating of those
muscles
to open and close all the veins arteries
and capillaries
i mean hundred thousand kilometers
is done by the neurology the nervous
system
so if any defect is there in the nervous
you will get to it through a cold shower
increasing
that is not last last practical question
maybe maybe the last one um
well so the cold shower is 30 seconds
and you can you can also use a warm
shower
afterwards if you want yes warm uh
before
you should end with the cold shower yes
and then
after 10 days you like to begin with
cold
which is better why because then your
mind comes into play
because you know you are going into the
cold then you connect with the stress
mechanisms inside yourself
you become stronger when you know you
are facing danger
when you face when you go to face a
a a force you set
your mind to it and that
is what we lost in our society it's
always comfort comfort comfort comfort
no seek discomfort then discomfort
becomes power
that's the point where you are learning
and there you get new power you get you
go past the conditioning
and that it's amazing what the call can
teach us